good evening and welcome to lorry prints
live tonight subject violence in the
media does the media have a stake and
what some are calling the growing
criminal epidemic or is it just another
in a long list of society's problems
joining us on the panel today is a
clinical psychologist and Harvard
University professor Morales Raja
evening Laurie and with us via satellite
phone is world-renowned psychopathic
terrorists and finalist in this year's
Last Comic Standing the Joker
mr. Joker how are you this evening good
Laurie I'm good
no mr. Joker what is your take on
violence's influence on the media oh I'm
for it no I mean do you believe it has
an effect well that's a very interesting
question Laurie on the one hand I don't
like children watching violent images
all the time I mean I plan to be a very
abusive father myself one day but I
don't consider myself the byproduct of
any destructive media I mean it's not
like I listen to Marilyn Manson and
that's what turn me into the person you
see today true by all outward
appearances I look like the lovechild of
gene Simmons and Ronald McDonald's
drunken grandma but that wasn't on the
orders of some sniveling emo kid whining
about his crappy life in the suburbs
professor Roger what is your take on
this well well I agree in some respects
about mr. Joker is saying Thank You
professor
I'll kill you less you have to admit
that some of the things that kids get
exposed to are way beyond the normal
that's just pop asteroid is it yeah with
all due respect professor people are
always trying to explain things away
when there's uh no explaining to do Lucy
who's didn't anyone watch I Love Lucy
here Ricky Ricardo Ethel the Mertzes God
what a bunch of dummies I where's mr.
head that's just well point being there
is no magic bullet out there I mean for
example just take a really good look at
me look at Mary are you looking yes good
you think this grin is a product of bad
television a pish-posh poppycock it's a
complex laundry list of various social
economical factors you can't just pin it
on TV and what did you grow up with as a
child I grew up with pokemons Laurie
that little yellow thing that chirps all
the time because you yeah I think he's
just darling but surely the media's had
some influence on your everyday well
sure but it doesn't control what I do
for example if I was to say wrap up your
dog and cat in explosives and force you
to choose between one of them which
would you choose
I suppose I would say my cat very wise
choice you might want a nickname him
boom boom oh and Laurie
fYI only idiots hide their house keys
under the doormat but you see Laurie I
made that choice me not Pokemon it's
just plain and simple while I'm mourning
the loss of my cherished house pet we do
have another call on the line
a mr. man would like to respond to your
argument mr. man you are on the air okay
I wonder who this is what gives you the
right to lecture us on what's morally
appropriate for the typical American
viewer oh well it is a free country no
thanks to you you see what he's doing
you see we do it this is so typical of
the kind of fascist mentality that I am
sorry I'm sorry do you two know each
other well for God's sakes wait a
newspaper Laurie seriously the quality
of this news show has gone down
significantly ever since new management
took over tell me about it well I hardly
think that's neither here nor there if
it was we're sure your news program
wouldn't pick it up true that well
getting back to the subject matter at
hand included a subject matter I want to
know why the hell the choker got out
here anyway well because he threatened
to blow our studio if we didn't well uh
what if I threatened to do the same well
you'll have to take that up with a
producer I'd if he gets a guest spot I
want my own trend Oh No
that's both demands like a catering
table filled with Krispy Kremes and
sauerkraut and a rocking chair that's
inflatable and I want a bowl of M&Ms
nothing but green M&Ms no no purple
purple
I want purple M&Ms in my trailer on the
double and they still make purple M&Ms I
don't make some purple M&Ms Gotham City
otherwise I will blow up an M&M factory
on the hour every other you're not
getting your purple M&Ms joking right me
you overblown twin confessor Raja your
thoughts am I gonna die if I don't agree
with a little oh yes yeah you suck no
you suck no you suck you suck no you
suck you suck you suck yourself what are
we doing this is silly
we should be on top of rooftops blow
each other up or something yeah this
isn't even a good news program boy you
said it hey you know what's good you
know it's good
Charlie Rose I'm pretty partial that Jim
Lear's newshour Hyundai intervener I
believe don't worry this program is over
hey bats what do you say we go over to
channel 6 and get a guest spot and
Gotham tonight oh I don't know okay okay
how about this how about this how about
I bust into the studio and take a dozen
hostages maybe break up a few explosives
and then we can chat sounds good All
Right see you uh
now what eight eight percent yeah yeah
it's good I wanna make the ten o'clock
news
of course oh and you and I are not so
different we're very much alike you
complete me blah blah blah yeah I know
the drill mr. man if I could ask you one
more
professor final thoughts I'm terrified
beyond the capacity for rational thought
aren't we all
well mr. Joker thank you for dropping by
you Laurie
it's been a pleasure and I must ask does
this mean you are not going to blow up
our studio I'll think about it
well I think that went rather well yes